we did the culture War show today and we
had uh Stephen Bonnell uh bottle Destiny
he's a liberal guy
um even after the show we're hanging out
and we were having disagreements but
Destiny is an honest guy he could be
wrong about something sometimes we all
are but I know that if we if we come and
have a conversation he's actually going
to try and make a point that he thinks
is true and honestly assess what we are
saying to him then you have the actual
cultural left which is people like AOC
who will just lie cheat and steal for
political power you have people like
Tulsi gabbard who was being honest in
what her views were and probably wrong
on some things same as most people are
but was being honest to you on why she
thought those things was genuinely
listening to you they're they're like
it's almost like the culture War
factions we always try to Define what
they are but I can tell you one
characteristic at the very least is if
you hold leftist political opinions but
tell the truth you're right wing